[Music]
why is there fair in the birthing area
very lives don't matter today oh and you
keep doing all your gangster stuff I'm
just trying to sell my house don't worry
about that
everybody's just trying to get along and
have a good life all of the races are
different just cuz they're different
doesn't mean anybody's better or worse
than anybody
hey yeah where's the diversity on I got
a do to my car I didn't ask for it but
the whole world is watching
okay don't like things I'm not here to
be your friend I need to know [ __ ] pop
up that you got my back can't hide it
work again let's have physical towels
like the face
what's my face with you and it needs a
lot more carnival of taffy do not wink
at me like that
we Adam not show us in room
certainly wait for the capital ratings
we are to counter what is
that's magic
it's like a new killer weapon that
grants wishes that's whatever you want
you want me taller or shorter you want
ten million dollars you're not stealing
it why
[Music]
you gotta get out of this neighborhood
you're gonna kill you tell me and that's
when the stoop is just gonna start magic
water have to secure it
you notice out of the Academy no they do
not
you're gonna keep coming
hey let's do it
days I can't get out of my head that's
just the dark side
[Music]
we might being a promise you're not in a
prophecy we're gonna stolen Toyota
Corolla
[Music]
you
[Music]